[Music]
a marvel juggernaut that flamed out
after only one sequel an edgy stylized
franchise that absolutely bombed on its
second outing blade runner more like
blade dunner these 11 franchises could
have been huge instead they flopped
after just one sequel
in 2002 scooby-doo proved to be a box
office hit and how could it not be a
live-action adaptation of one of the
most popular cartoons in history
scooby-doo was a wacky romp that could
appeal to youngsters and nostalgic
adults alike however live action
adaptations of cartoons tend to be
projects that only work financially once
the novelty is worn off for most
audiences after a single installment the
smurfs ii garfield a tale of two kitties
peter rabbit two the list of examples go
on and on scooby-doo also suffered from
this phenomenon as its sequel scooby-doo
two monsters unleashed was a box office
disappointment the film's 181 million
dollar worldwide gross was roughly 35
percent worse than the global box office
hall of its predecessor monsters
unleashed may have delivered more
familiar scooby-doo foes from their
original cartoon but this new
installment suffered from mixed reviews
along with a less hospitable march
release date compared to the first
film's june launch pad with these
financial shortcomings another
theatrical live-action scooby-doo pinned
by james gunn and meant to take place in
scotland was given the axe we're gonna
die stay positive we're gonna die
quickly
lara croft as a video game character has
been plundering ruins for decades which
has turned this fictional figure into
one of the more enduring characters of
1990s video games on the big screen
though lara croft hasn't been so lucky
with the original live action movie
adaptation of tomb raider starring
angelina jolie sputtering out after just
two entries it didn't initially seem
like the franchise would be so
short-lived lara croft tomb raider made
serious bank at the worldwide box office
in the summer of 2001 capitalizing on
the popularity of croft and jolie's
increasing star power the film came
along at the perfect time in every
respect unfortunately it wasn't
particularly beloved by audiences or
critics despite its sizable box office
returns when lara croft the cradle of
life dropped into cinemas in the summer
of 2003 moviegoers gave the production
the cold shoulder with the film raking
in significantly less cash than its
predecessor it was game over for the
lara croft movie franchise thanks to
this extremely disappointing box office
development this staple of video game
history wouldn't find its way back to
movie theaters until its reboot 15 years
later
the original the exorcist wasn't just a
hit it was a pop culture sensation there
was no going back for american horror
after the release of william friedkin's
magnum opus with every scary movie
released in its wake existing in its
shadow this level of influence meant it
was only a matter of time before the
producers of the movie decided to try
their hand at continuing the story
despite the definitive ending of the
original film exorcist 2 the heretic hit
theaters in 1977 four years after the
original while the exorcist was greeted
with universal praise the heretic became
one of the worst reviewed horror movies
of all time original exorcist director
william friedkin was among the chorus of
moviegoers who despised the project
going so far as to declare that the
heretic was one of the worst films he'd
ever watched what inspired this deluge
of vitriol mostly a confounding plot and
moments that elicited giggles rather
than screams with this kind of response
the prospect of an ongoing exorcist
franchise suddenly seemed a lot less
probable than before the exorcist only
wound up being resurrected in 1990 when
william peter blatty author of the novel
the original exorcist was based on
decided to write and direct a third
installment himself the exorcist iii is
much more well regarded than the heretic
probably because its creator actually
had an understanding of the source
material
diesel is best known for being fast and
furious on the silver screen but dominic
toretto isn't his only character that
loves a good burst of adrenaline in
2002's xxx diesel plays xander cage a
super spy who uses extreme sports to
save the world
you've just entered
the xander zone
xxx was a solid box office performer and
was enough of a moneymaker to ensure
that it would get a couple of sequels if
james bond could keep going and going
xander cage could surely sustain a few
more installments a sequel did emerge
with the 2005 featured xxx state of the
union but the production had a massive
issue with diesel or rather his absence
to the producer's dismay diesel chose
not to return for the sequel and had to
be replaced by ice cube while the rapper
turned actor is certainly no slouch the
original idea was to create an iconic
character that people could follow for
endless adventures not somebody who
would get swapped out after a single
installment unsurprisingly state of the
union crumbled at the box office and
destroyed any hopes for a sprawling
franchise while the fast and furious
movies have managed to deliver new
adventures on a regular basis it would
take more than a decade for another xxx
installment the return of xander cage to
hit theaters with you guessed it diesel
returning as xander cage
the original blade runner wasn't exactly
a box office smash but it proved to be
so enormously influential that a sequel
was an inevitability after years of
development blade runner 2049 hit
theaters in october 2017 courtesy of
director denis villenov before the
sequel's release volnov and producer
ridley scott openly discussed their
hopes and story ideas for a potential
blade runner 3. sadly those hopes were
immediately threatened by the box office
earnings despite lots of pre-release
hype 2049 underperformed on its opening
weekend what once looked like a surefire
way to re-energize the blade runner
universe suddenly wasn't looking so
promising this critical problem didn't
get rectified in the weeks afterward
either as 2049 ended up losing money
once its worldwide box office run was
finished with this development the idea
of doing further blade runner movies was
shelved with vilnev moving his sci-fi
storytelling abilities into the world of
dune instead despite both entries in the
franchise scoring critical acclaim box
off his woes have so far kept further
blade runner movies from gracing the
silver screen
box office expectations often miss
severely when it comes to comedy sequels
while projects like city slickers and
horrible bosses made big bucks at the
box office their respective follow-ups
just failed to click with moviegoers
still the allure of delivering the rare
the hangover part 2 or 22 jump street at
the box office means that studios still
try their luck at launching hit comedy
franchises this includes a follow-up to
the 2014 sleeper hit neighbors which
ended up becoming one of seth rogen's
biggest movies the same could not be
said for neighbors 2 sorority rising a
follow-up that flipped the script by
having rogan and rose byrne team up with
their former enemy zac efron to take
down a sorority house that's right
i'm switching sides
the result was a project that just
didn't connect with moviegoers partially
because the premise didn't seem all that
different from the original although
technically profitable by making 108
million dollars worldwide on a 35
million dollar budget neighbors 2 was a
massive step down from the original
neighbor's film any potential for
neighbors taking a cue from the hangover
and going on for an entire trilogy was
stopped cold with sorority rising which
turned out to be both a franchise killer
and yet another example of an
underperforming comedy sequel
at the start of the 2010s director
roland emmerich announced that there
were finally plans to make a sequel to
independence day not only that but the
filmmaker openly discussed his ambitions
to make multiple follow-ups to his 1996
sci-fi disaster movie even though only a
single sequel was eventually greenlit
emmerich was eager to discuss his
detailed ambitions for the future of the
series ultimately however emmerich would
not get a chance to realize the entirety
of his vision the original independence
day was one of the biggest box office
hits of the 1990s but its sequel was one
of the biggest disappointments of 2016.
the project's financial troubles could
be chalked up to all sorts of factors
including intense competition from other
blockbusters that summer along with
relatively lousy marketing whatever the
reasons for resurgence failing to meet
box office expectations were it was
quickly made clear that there would not
be a third independence day
nobody involved with the original speed
imagine the movie sustaining a series of
sequels especially not director jan
debunk alas the film's massive box
office intake meant that de bont was
contractually obligated to direct a
second installment but this time it
would be without keanu reeves the loss
of their leading man should have been
the first warning sign for the producers
at 20th century fox but that didn't stop
them from pouring over 110 million
dollars into the budget it certainly
didn't help that the intense and
claustrophobic setting of a bus from the
original speed was traded out for a
massive boat an idea that de bonk claim
came to him in a dream of course speed 2
cruise control ended up being more of a
nightmare june 1997 was an exceptionally
crowded time for blockbusters meaning
the film had to compete with the likes
of batman and robin conair and the lost
world jurassic park it didn't stand a
chance and cruise control quickly became
nothing more than a punchline it's
unknown if there were any initial plans
to develop a speed 3 but the failure of
this doomed follow-up ensured that
studio executives wouldn't try to kick
the speed franchise into high gear again
the enduring popularity of lee child's
jack reacher books meant that it was
only a matter of time before reacher
would get to star in a theatrical film
this opportunity finally emerged in
december 2012 with jack reacher which
functioned as yet another star vehicle
for tom cruise the production wasn't as
big of a hit as the novels but jack
reacher still proved reasonably
profitable on its more restrained budget
paramount pictures which wasn't exactly
bursting with franchises in the
mid-2010s was willing to gamble on jack
reacher a sequel jack reacher never go
back wouldn't emerge until october 2016
a whopping four years after its
predecessor debuted in theaters the
original jack reacher was well liked but
was it beloved enough to maintain
audience entrance for so long no not
really you're right
the numbers don't add up
never go back ended up flopping killing
off jack reacher as a viable theatrical
franchise in the process when the
character finally did reappear it was in
an amazon tv series starring alan
richson in the title role
certain marvel superheroes have no
shortage of big screen hits iron man and
captain america have both received
plenty of solo outings and crossover
appearances while spider-man seems
destined to be rebooted and reimagined
over and over again however there are
plenty of other figures from this comic
book company's vast library of
characters that have been less
successful at maintaining longevity in
theaters case in point ghost rider a
darker more edgy superhero that
initially seemed to be poised for
franchise success when he made his big
screen debut in 2007 the first ghost
rider film which starred nicholas cage
in the title role was a solid box office
performer ghost rider yielded a sequel
ghost rider spirit of vengeance but
there were a few problems that ended up
causing the franchise to crash and burn
most glaringly there was a five year gap
between the two ghost rider movies a
stretch of time during which the first
two iron man films were released at the
end of the day this new ghost rider
simply didn't offer anything new to
audiences an r rating might have saved
the series but executives decided to
play it safe instead while there were
originally plans for a third ghost rider
the dismal box office intake of spirit
of vengeance slammed the brakes on those
prospects the character has yet to
surface in the mcu but a different
version of the character made an
appearance on marvel's agents of shield
tv series
when sin city first hit theaters in
april 2005 it was considered new and
fresh mainstream american cinema wasn't
exactly yearning for more noir tributes
but robert rodriguez's heavily stylized
world made the film stand out from the
rest with several other sin city stories
from the comics yet to be adapted it
seemed like only a matter of time before
sin city became an ongoing franchise
however it took nearly a decade before
sin city a dane to kill for finally
ended up in movie theaters by the time a
dame to kill four rolled around in
august 2014 the cinematic landscape had
changed dramatically the visual look of
sin city had already been copied to
death by other filmmakers and audiences
had simply moved on resulting in a
disastrous box office hall any plans for
additional sensitivity movies were
immediately shelved unlikely ever to see
the light of day what at once seemed
like a foolproof franchise quickly
turned into two movies with vastly
differing receptions check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]